[Musique]
je m'appelle michel rabagliati je suis
auteur de bande dessinée la famille dans
mon oeuvre est important dès le départ
dès le premier album les questions de
soyaux
la blonde de paul dans ma blonde ma
fille ma grande tante je place mon père
ma mère mon père par exemple est un
français qui a été élevé ici mieux les
manières française et des petites
expressions dans ce qu'il dit qui sait
ce qui donne la saveur à ce personnage
là parce qu'ils parce qu'il répond pas
comme tout le monde je fais un portrait
de maman qui était une femme très
attentionné c'est vraiment la femme au
foyer des années 60 qui n'est grand
parent c'est spécial c'est comme danser
ma grand-mère et ma grande temps qui est
à côté de chez nous là j'ai deux
magnifiques personnages avec avec
jeannette et denise c'est les français
c'est que ça fait en plus des
parisiennes
l'antagonisme en ma mère et ses fameux
la maman qu'une femme d'un milieu
populaire montréalais qui est en kaki
clash avec ses du c2 madame là qui
viennent de france c'est un peu dans le
fond à cause de rose que j'ai commencé à
faire de la bande dessinée donc ma fille
alice puis à alès mots beaucoup beaucoup
grande et qui sont la vraie vie c'est un
peu avec avec cette idée là de vraie vie
que je suis parti avec pages là j'avais
envie de raconter les vraies choses on
voit paul qui se rapproche des alliés
mais ses bottes il met son imperméable
il va se promener avec l dehors il
profite de sa présence pour raconter ses
propres souvenirs de l'an prochain la
campagne
comment lui a vécu son enfance donc le
contact avec sa fille fait que lui un
contact avec sa propre enfance elle
ramène à son propre enfance puis je
jamais la lâcher parce que présente un
super personnage que je donne toujours
envie de parler d'elle
mes parents surtout déjà qu'ils ont
comme vu que tu as un rêveur j'étais
quelqu'un qui avait besoin de temps et
puis beaucoup de d'espacé pour dessiner
rêver vraiment de m'avoir laissé niaiser
sa table du salon
ils m'ont absolument laisser faire puis
moi je les remercie toujours pas ce que
c'est ça qui m'a servi le plus
[Musique]